our little yellow book pick today is a
mini garden you can grow on your
countertop the personal rise garden
in just 30 days you can grow and harvest
herbs and veggies and greens and like a
little farmer from the future you can
control it all with an app on your phone
i know oh you thought you knew what this
was no you did it i didn't
um well let us explain
well and you you always talk about
growing up like in the farm oh area oh
yeah i picked spinach i worked at a bulb
factory i worked at a berry stand where
i'd say have a very good day but
but now we live in new york city i can't
be a farmer drew well and this
technology can help you it uses led
technology so you can grow year-round
everything from mint to basil to
tomatoes and baby eggplant
so my farmer days are back
it's a very good day
and the team at rise gardens has a
special treat for all of our guests in
the audience today that's right you're
getting a personal indoor
[Applause]
and cultivate the good stuff because i
hope that you can take this energy that
i witnessed today and take it with you
let's cultivate our gardens have a
fantastic day
[Music]